[Music]
okay so
future's a wonderful art package that
does like a lot of
voodoo behind the scenes so that you can
easily run code in a separate art
process
and i think that in itself deserves a
ton of praise because the api is so
simple
and is so useful
um i actually don't even use the
shorthand api because i like the very
direct explicit feature
where you say hey run this code in the
future and then
go get a value
and i think that in itself is a
wonderful handshake and i really like
this and i really
enjoy embracing this
um this is very useful if you have like
hey i run a i want to run 100
simulations and i have 10 cores
let's you know make a plan to use all 10
cores and
just churn over those and we can
actually use r on all separate 10 cores
or in 10 different r processes hopefully
your machine is smart enough to use all
the cores
but
like typically r is a single
single worker is the way i want to think
of it
and so if it's a single worker
you know you churn through it serially
but if we are able to use future we can
now turn through it in parallel using as
many workers as we have available
and i think that's awesome uh it works
out really well um
and we can actually kind of take a quick
peek at this so we library future and
then we can set up plan um and say
multi-session that's just a good default
um
then we can say workers is two for the
demo purposes or for the other example i
could set it to be ten you know that
works great as well or a hundred you
know it doesn't matter
um but two works
um and then here
i have my like simulations from 1 to 10
that i want to run
and i'm going to create the future i'm
going to set up the future
i'm going to say it was created and then
i'm going to return that future object
and then finally at the end we will look
at all of the values
for each of the vowels
so let's library plan
run valves and it immediately goes into
the first two are created right away and
then we start to go through this just a
little bit slower but in pairs of twos
and that's really neat like if we're
looking at it with assist sleep 2 that
should have taken
what 20 seconds
but if we
do a um
start is cis dot time
and
end
system
uh what is it
and minus start
maybe this will work
try it again
so it took 10 seconds and this is
awesome we have two workers
and well it took nine seconds not really
ten but um we have two workers and you
know it all finished up very quickly in
parallel not 20 seconds that's the
important part
um we can get in later to like where
that extra second went but i'm not too
worried it's you know roughly ten so
that's the good part
and if we get the values
we have one to ten
perfect
this is really neat um but one of the
things that was interesting is
when you notice and you watched how it
was working i could not actually execute
this
end
or this n minus start until the l apply
had finished processing
that's a little weird because i'm saying
hey dear future please run this in the
future
and this is because it actually had ran
out of workers to submit jobs to
so if i switch this and i say workers is
100
plan
i start do the vows and
it should go
much much faster
oh it uh
let's actually cancel that let's say
workers is 10
you know because it's actually making
100 r sessions uh we don't want to do
that
um
so let's set up to be 10.
now they're created very quickly
um and so let's actually just redo the
whole thing because i didn't even hit
the end
time point so it took two seconds you
know submitting the jobs is not trivial
um takes time
but it's a lot faster than if we are to
do this
in serial so uh that's good and we can
look at the values everything is great
so
that's a lot of fun like it's it's
really neat like how
all of that
is able to be done
um
but there's that funny situation when
you run out of workers and what happens
you know when we run out of workers and
my thought is it just immediately
returned
and turns out it actually blocks
blocking has very big implications for
shiny and for plumber
shiny
will actually treat future processes
very similar to a promise
and a promise is a a
thing in r that says like you can chain
these promises but you can also kind of
interleave the processing of promises
promises kind of jump into later but
the idea is that you can you can
interleave the processing of promises so
if you have a job that takes a very long
amount of time
you could actually break it up into a
chain of multiple promises and that
would allow other things to work in in
between
rather than waiting for your job to
finish completely
this idea can also be scaled up for
shiny in that like uh
what if we have multiple users coming in
if this user comes in and says please
process my model
and it's one big block of code
no one else gets to do anything all of
your cores are being underutilized
nothing
and so instead you could use promises
to say if you could break up that
section of your model or processing of
that model into multiple multiple
promises
then
other users can come in and just say oh
give me hello world give me hello world
and no problem they don't have to wait
till the end
um
so i think it's really cool um
future we treat just like a promise and
it gets upgraded and the result is is
handled accordingly the bad part is
future blocks when submitting a job if
there is no workers available
so there is a brand new function in the
promises package called future promise
and a future promise for all practical
purposes is just
i promise to execute this in the future
so for the
majority of what you'll do whenever you
would normally say future parentheses
you can kind of replace it with
future promise parentheses
so in our code
if we were to come in here
and let's actually copy this and make a
new script
and
library
promises and clear out
our output all right
so
we say library
future library promises set up our
multi-session let's actually adjust our
workers back down to two
okay
and then we will adjust our future to be
a future
promise
let's try running this
so
the time
finished right away and actually i was
able to get control back to the console
right away
and then these messages started just
showing up when it started completing
and submitting these jobs and i think
that's a very subtle difference but it's
a very important difference
because if i run this again
of calculating the vowels i can actually
come in here and say one plus one
let's say two plus two two plus three
and i'm able to submit this work
while waiting for the future to finish
and
now my main r session is not blocked
this is super cool this is that
wow
because now i can process other people's
work
while not waiting
for that big future job to finish or to
be submitted
and that is very very beneficial
so uh workers is an arbitrary thing uh
you can set it to what you want
uh
it's
dependent on what you want to use them
for
so if you have things like
re you know submitting data to my sql or
you know
not labor intensive tasks but you need
to do a bunch of them
then maybe you have like two to three
the amount of cores that you have
um because they're not going to be
utilizing that much work and you know
it's okay you could even go higher than
that if it's not
a real you know intense task but if
you're you know counting
all the numbers in fibonacci it's very
you know computationally expensive
then maybe you do cores minus one
so if i have eight cores on my machine i
might say ah workers equals seven so
that i can click on my computer still
otherwise you'll have
all of your cores maxed out and your
computer is kind of
rendered useless
but
it you know it's up to you and how you
want to use it
workers are not cores directly but your
computer will try to
offload them and have them processed
because it's not
in the computer's best interest to put
them on the same core
so
plumber plumber runs on http uv just
like shiny so a lot of these concepts
work just the same as if we are doing
plumber api or a shiny application
the concept of working and using futures
and promises
just extends from one to the other
so in plumber let's imagine that i have
two functions that i want to expose in
an api
a plumber is a r package that will allow
you to
create a web api from our code uh just
using a couple little decorators
in this case i have two functions the
fast calc and slow calc
and i can expose them as routes
with the at get
fast and at get slow
and for me in the case of the demo for
this
the id is just representing the
submission order but the calculation can
do whatever it wants with the parameters
things like that
but then that way when you see something
like slow one and slow two we know that
slow two is submitted after slow one
even if they are very close together in
submission time
cool
so plummer handles this and in this case
we're going to have four routes we're
going to have a fast route a slow a slow
and then a fast route
and if we were to process it
all four submissions kind of done at the
same time
it would look like this because r has
only one worker so we do the fast route
and then it responds and then okay it's
done and then we do a slow route and
then it processes and it takes a very
long
time
and no one else can do anything and slow
three is just sitting there waiting to
do work
then it's done and then we respond great
slow three comes in and it starts to
process and it is very slow
it's
taking its time and fast forward has to
wait for all of this processing time to
work
and then okay we're done and then now we
can respond and then fast forward can
come in
and it processes really quickly
and then it can respond and we're done
so great awesome
those four requests
came in and they took
about 20 seconds if we think that slow
takes 10 seconds to calculate and fast
is roughly instantaneous
so the fast comes in it processes right
away slow comes in takes 10 seconds to
process
and then slow 3 had to wait that whole
time and then slow 4 had to wait even
all 20 seconds for it to be processed
even though they kind of arrived at the
same time
this red area is bad this is something
that we can optimize i can't necessarily
make slow calculation faster
but i can reduce the waiting time and
that's a goal
so with plumber we can do this using
future
and
this is just talking about using futures
and so like how they can work with
plumber and with shiny a lot of people
don't know this so like if you're
compiling a pdf in shiny if you return a
future
from your reactive or your output or an
observe
it will put it in this promise and it
will listen to it
it's awesome
read the docs but
you can offload things quite well
the only change in this situation is
that we're going to wrap our slow
calculation in the future
and then we will resubmit it
and
from
before it took 20 seconds and now it
will take
10 seconds
and there's been fast 4 got reduced by
20 seconds total
and slow 3 did not have to wait and so
it was 10 seconds faster
so all the wait time in this example
was able to be removed we can't reduce
the processing time but we can at least
like remove or get rid of the wait time
and that's awesome and so this is how
future can help you do that
cool
so how would this look like
with plumber plumbers typically or is
always in the main r session or the main
worker
and we can add extra workers future
worker one future worker two
so having those same routes come in
where the slow is actually wrapped in
future it will look like so
um oh yeah the future worker we're only
doing it in the process step
so okay fast comes in it is processed
really quickly great we respond awesome
slow comes in hey it's a future let's
offload it great this allows the main
our process to come in and do the same
thing with slow three
since we have enough workers for the
jobs then slow or sorry fast four is
able to process immediately
slow two just happened to finish so we
can send it off and same with slow three
like a lot more going on a lot of moving
parts but
it's really nice because it allows
to offload that slow processing
somewhere else to free up that main r
worker so you can respond to health
checks you can you know have other users
in shiny do simple reactivity and it's
not going to be a big deal you're not
waiting for someone else to finish
running their model why should someone
else's shiny session alter my shiny
session
and futures and promises will help you
do that
so that's where we get that 20 second
save
by habit by being in parallel
so some limitations you were talking
about how many cores do i do
like you know we saw i was trying to add
100 cores at one one point and it my
computer just kind of blew up a little
bit because it was spawning 100 r
sessions like uh maybe not the best idea
two to three is pretty good or one to
one if you're computationally uh intense
um for your processing
um spawning a future is not instant kind
of like a quarter of a second
but um
if a quarter of a second really doesn't
mean much to you for time then future is
perfect if a quarter of a second does
mean a lot to you uh maybe don't offload
it to an external um rsr session because
maybe that communication overhead is too
much and you're already losing time
so you know that's kind of where it
leads into the processing power is
finite and memory size is finite maybe
if your models take up 10 gigs of memory
maybe you only use two workers it's
still better than zero
what happens when i run out of workers
so
let's pretend we have six slow routes
all being handled by future and how like
what would happen you know by slow three
we will run out of workers
so slow one comes in offloaded worker
one great slow two offloaded worker two
slow three
blocking the main r session
and
the main r session is still blocked
because now slow 4 is blocking
slow 5 is still blocking the main r
session
slow
6 is still blocking the main r session
because it can't be offloaded somewhere
now it's been offloaded
fast 7 is still blocking the main r
session
but it's kind of free
and then now we can undo
the
the result of the future
values and
now the main r session is unblocked it's
kind of free
now we can process slow five and now we
can process slow six but while we were
waiting to offload slow three four five
and six to offload them to workers the r
process was not usable the main r
process so in the case of plumber you
could not do a health check in the case
of shiny i cannot load up a new r
session or a new tab like it's blocked
nothing can be done
and if we were to visualize this you
know the processing time takes 30
seconds in total offloaded in pairs and
there's actually a new thing where the
results of slow one and slow two do not
get returned until 20 seconds in that
was when the main r session became free
and slow 3 and 4 had to wait slow 5 and
6 had to wait fast 7 had to wait
and that's not good like we want to try
to reduce that wait time as much as
possible
to add in as well
this is the area where there were more
future requests than future workers
this is also the area where the r
session
plus the final end
is where the r session is blocked the
main r session
um that is where things are unusable
even if you're only just handing them
off
or you're waiting
this gray area is bad and we'd like to
minimize it as much as possible
cool
so this is where future promise came in
promise to execute using a future
if we were to do this with future
promise the execution time
would look like this
um
the items slow 1 and slow 2 respond
immediately slow 3 and 4
just like we're before but the big one
is fast 7 is now actually executing
immediately
it is not waiting for anyone
fun animations and also more fun
animations
the big difference here is
where the gray bars are at in this case
the gray bars are only at the start when
we're resolving the values for one and
two and resolving the values for three
and four and also for five and six can't
get rid of those
but in between
completely free you can run health check
routes on plumber you can start new
sessions in shiny you're not blocked
everything is awesome like any time you
say future parentheses just say future
promise
solve a lot of issues
and for the most part as long as
everything's scoped just like
they should be then everything will
behave as expected
for the most part it's just a one-to-one
drop-in for comparison let's see how the
animation works for this one so we have
all of our one through six slow routes
and then a fast route
and the addition here is that we're
gonna have this promise queue of promise
to compute with future so it's a pre-cue
not a post queue
so we have this pre-cue because there's
no workers available so we'll just say i
will
i promise to to do this
so we can now
execute fast 7 immediately and then slow
one and slow to have finished processing
after 10 seconds
and the order may be a little fuzzy here
but for the most part like they go up in
and out in pairs
just you know you can only animate so
well in keynote so
um
yeah but throughout the whole process
the
our main r session is is free like 90
98 of time not like blocked 60 percent
[Music]